all right so this is Tim Burton's Alice
in Wonderland what the fuck happened
here
god dammit fucking movie if I ever gone
a movie that a story and a director that
go hand in hand I mean should just give
us probably love the most perfect
interpretations of a classic book or
even two books you want make that
argument and good fucking god
I was so pissed off at this movie I was
so angry uh interesting story when we
saw this film you were hyped as you are
for all too well no no no I got taken
down when I saw the second trailer and I
went oh no I dungeon you're hiding the
first trailer I was really excited um I
had felt for a while that I've been
getting burnt out on Tim Burton so the
fact that Disney's name was attached to
it was not helping me any even though
just me I already have probably the best
Alice in Wonderland really yeah but
anyway so we went to see it and I just
remember watching it and just like what
the fuck is this when we left the cinema
like I remember turning to you as as
we're like walking back to the car and
I'm just like I don't remember a single
fucking thing that happened in that
movie I literally forgot about the
entire movie within five minutes of
seeing it like I remembered something
from the beginning I was so much
something from the end and yeah yeah I
literally I'm like this was the most
useless unmemorable movie like I had
seen at that point to date I was like
wow I I don't remember a single fucking
thing and like that was the case until I
saw it again when we did the NC like
whatever somebody has like what would
you think of movies like I don't know I
don't remember it and it's literally
like I blacked out it just gets worse
and worse every time II this movie was
so I'm glad the review turned out well
there that but it was so painful to edit
cuz I love the story about someone la I
love the possibility and I love Tim
Burton and like I said
I here's a director who has been
criticized for years and years not
having enough of a story to his films
and here is a boy that has no story any
kids on the planet so as you do it gives
the story Oh story that you might have a
story in the end to the toilet too
complicated that's not long enough about
my son
let's not dump that all in Burnet there
are crappy screenwriters no I mean that
they're worth you know it's like if he's
kind of like your kid that way it's just
like oh I can just see the visuals I
could safely apply the age like getting
a shit about the know and that's I can
see the apes moving and I'm abroad it's
funny you brought that movie up because
when I saw Alice in Wonderland that's
the only thing I thought I was like wow
it's exactly like playing games I don't
remember that much about this movie it
was the exact same thing it's like let's
take something that was a complicated
story with many nuances or at least in
case of Alice in Wonderland complex and
it's just so reality like it's nonsense
and let's attach some sort of ooh
military metaphor ooh big battle ooh
like that was it that's all I remember
the exact same thing that happened to
plan out of the Apes and you know it all
just came down to some stupid battle at
the end that nobody cares and this is my
biggest problem with it cuz I can't even
give burning the credit like he's not
the only one who's done this what is
with this fucking thing that people do
or they're like I'm gonna reinterpret
Alice in Wonderland no it's gonna be
this this big metaphor for like like
giant battles and this all mean
something and and this and that it's
like it's a story that may have
satirical elements to it but it's still
about nonsense they're like no we need
to defeat the Jabberwocky and fulfilled
the prophecy there's another fucking
hostages don't keep fucking watching the
prophecy and like she's now like fucking
Joan of Arc like wielding the sword I'm
like where I want this movie I'm not a
buyers movie where is this shit coming
from that's not what Alice of Wonderland
is about it's not some fucking medieval
battle movie it's not fucking Braveheart
and I've seen this again and again and
then like you know like Once Upon a Time
tried to do their own version and
there's all this political
trig and I'm like how could you have
political intrigue in a nation that's
just run by crazy people it's just a
bunch of cokes
I mean North Korea makes more fucking
sense the fucking Wonderland great now
we're going to lose all the North Korean
dealers that we never have this will be
worse than when we attacked the Amish I
just know everyone's gonna look for when
we make fun of you but I'm hoping it's a
joke if they don't watch TV or Internet
oh just did it bothers it really fuck
about it it really bothers me like does
it bother you that it's like let's take
a story that is essentially supposed to
be nonsense like that is my man and try
to all of this logic yeah you are
something out the phone you were sucking
up everything that make I also wonder
lay wonderful deciding you have a about
prophesies and plans and military exams
geez grata jeez and I won't if you're oh
they're supposed to come out and say
that they want why are you making this
so boring why are you making a story
that was so much fun and just so
creative and just like this nameless
world of imagination you are limiting it
to the most boring terrible degree and
the most make you like every other
Hollywood are you just overused piece of
crap tropes I mean we have that it's
called Star Wars in every single fucking
movie that's been ripping off star wars
send Star Wars yeah it's it's amazing
it's not like we have a shortage of
stories that don't have the lone hero
the prophecy someone that thinks it's a
dream so sort of evil person in China
every young adult book is pretty much
this now but we've had tons from doom to
Narnia the Star Wars I need if you do it
then right then if you really grow good
but it is even do as you're trying to
bring it to something just clearly 100%
does not belong and it just infuriates
me because somewhere there's an Alice in
Wonderland version that's going to come
out and it's got a perfect mix of like
both something a kind of new and
interpretation like the original Disney
one and really close to the book
well as much as I love the original
Disney one I think is probably the best
one it still really does the books so
long both the books are so long and had
something I got dead some yeah you had
to condense a lobby would it be great to
see those come to life but there's been
so many versions that they phone to the
Christmas Carol trap where they try to
do word-for-word what happens and it
loses the strangeness you need to update
a little bit know this this is the
equivalent of trying to take something
as loony as Tommy Wiseau's the room and
turn it into a real serious drama and
then failing that's what it's like it's
like it was never meant to be that well
maybe he wanted to be dead but it's
obviously not and trying to make sense
out of it you know and try to put some
realistic plot attached to it is not
going to save it you can't fucking save
no and this is one of those worse in the
case file so wandering life doesn't need
to be safe neither does the room the
room stands beautifully as the weird
fucked-up thing it is that this is one
of those where it's like I sauce with my
wife's family at the time and like they
are not into you know anything nearly as
weird as what we like and they don't
think that much about films there's
nothing wrong with it you all go just
enjoy something that's on the screen
fine and they came out just liking cuz
you know it's weird it's Tim Burton okay
I need my dose of weird and that's what
it feels like to me it feels like hey
for people that don't really want to
explore the strange side or anything
like that be just want a little dose yet
look I'm up there from a little quirky
okay I saw Elsa Wonderland I thought
again
I like the Ellison Wonder ya know and
it's one of the things where I'm not
saying they were faking it or anything
like that but just to truly explore just
the genius and the sir reality of those
original books which are very hard to
translate I don't want to be done it
could be done much better past the hot
topic I looked inside a 30 second time
quirky and I'm just I'm just blown away
by how many people like this and what a
big hit it was because I mean I just
can't imagine going back and watching
this film to get out of pleasure
I took the guys not I write it to get
worse because what I treated with
indifference the first time I actively
hated the same yeah it's for just the
more you think about it makes less and
less sense
you stupid dog you probably called it
wonder man yeah
Oh silly me and it is doing everything
in its power not to be Alice in
Wonderland even though I fucking call
Alice in Wonderland I met what I said
when Care Bears of wonder lay was a more
faithful adaptation Oh Tobias I do miss
but I'm so bored
don't uh oh god I just enough that hey
there's one whole thing felt and that's
like it felt paint-by-number like even
by like Wayne Tim Burton standards it's
like okay we got a quirky art design but
like the beginning felt like fuckin
Pirates of the Caribbean got same sort
of blond English girl like direct out of
some pirates casting call I one more
something something something something
more and then goes to Wonderland and
then at the end it's just like oh I'm
gonna run my own company and sales ships
and and then she goes and she meets Jack
Sparrow somewhere like it just dark you
know and I'll say it just looked like
every other movie at the time that's
what bother me too was watered down it
didn't even like I've seen more
interesting looking Tim Burton films and
this should have been the most
interesting booking of all is Alice in
fucking Wonderland some of the signs are
cool like the the Queen looks cool and
and that's what pisses me off - they try
so hard in many respects to really kind
of make it look like a book like the
Queen with the big head and stuff like
that but they love random moments where
it's like all the heads in the bloody
motor whatever I'm like what film are
Waya now like it's not so goofy that all
of a sudden we've got severed heads just
floating around me don't get me wrong
it's like I'm fine with it if the rest
of the movie was like that that would
have been cool nice but yeah I mean if
you kind of do this like make it like
yeah even it's like American McGee's
Alice like yeah but even the dark gritty
goth angle doesn't work because American
McGee's Alice did it so much better and
so much more adult and just so much
better designs and including that's what
I thought I thought it was going to be
like that and that was like I don't care
if they did it first I'm like well Tim
burns got a hold of this like this will
be really fucked up like it was like
nothing there was the head thing is the
closest thing we got to anything even
remotely disturbing like but hey
he doesn't fit in like all those other
girls so she must have a really delicate
did you know this is like rape from
literally literally like whoever wrote
it like I know you remember the credits
cuz I don't remember a single thing
about it nothing I can tell you is Danny
Elfman did the music and had frickin
Helena Bonham Carter in it Oh
antidepressant I believe that that's all
you need to know um oh and Alan Rickman
just cuz I remember on the round um
you're distracted by Chris Riley's
incredible cameo okay the Jabberwock I
don't even remember that
yo that's right payments relate your
Christopher Lee and then Alison would
only move away coming Opeth giant
monster that can you could just replace
the Selena RL snarl fucking idiot
Christopher Lee is a heavy metal about
the Jabberwocky is way more interesting
than April Wright is oh and you know and
this was one of the most therapeutic
reviews to do because so many people
were like what's wrong with you you know
and this was in the book stop
just shut up what this was on that one
yeah it's like that what's in the book
did you read anything else outside of
whatever the fuck you're comparing do
you have any comprehension of theme or
mood or character or story or feel
anything by this written word here they
said those written words now true they
replaced the w with you it just made
under labor yeah everything else was
pretty faithful fuck you no fuck you
I just had to get that out when so she
went back to Wonderland if either the
Jabberwocky came back and then sail the
ship around the world yeah but did you
know that wasn't a bunch of guys in the
metal armor and everything I mean it's
like I don't remember
wow I mean it's just one of those things
where it's like at some point when and
again I still I still stay I had her
dance to a bad Boingo sound dragon in
the book
good boy go boy go Susan you answer the
elfin um no I tell Mary where we were
talking to you go rafter and he has
talked about that cdc-wonder the weird
thing is like they play music to that
scene but in their reality when there's
no music so he's just going fucking nuts
haha I would have prepared no no that
would've been hilarious that cut back to
all including Alice just staring at the
bat after life it's one of those things
where it's like Alex if you like the
movie okay but don't don't try to say
it's the boat don't try to say this is
faithful don't try to say they captured
what Alice in Wonderland is about or the
fee or anything related to Alice and one
no they may have cut out metric tons of
self in the Disney film but what about
what Ellison when it comes to the spirit
of it it's where the Burton film and the
Byrne film at best is just a bad Tim
Burton movie
it's literally they went through all of
this screenwriting tropes in previous
Burton films all the outsider wants
something more Oh like you could just
literally put the darkness oh I just
hate this awesome I hate it so much
because I love Alice in Wonderland so
much and I meant what I said when they
were probably gonna be a lot more
interpretations of it but what a film
like this is a hit and people try to say
yeah you got it you got also one of them
what's wrong with you Doug they did it
right they got Alice in Wonderland you
were encouraging them to take other
wonderful stories that made it means
more and Sharaf eyeing it and you're
encouraging them to go and say you don't
we this is what people want this is good
we're declaring this good and this is
more what people are looking for and
right now in terms of movies it's like I
think we're in a pretty okay spot for
movies now like I said the Dark Age of
movies is past for a while but it's like
we're still encouraging them to come out
with stuff like this with these
interpretations when there could be
wonderful creative brilliant
interpretations happening if you gave
them to more capable artists and we
supported that you know right now we're
seeing that in TV with kid shows and
stuff like that with stuff like Steven
universe and
time and gravity falls and stuff and
we're creating new ones and that's great
but when you try to remake something
like this and say no this is correct
this is the spirit of the book I mean
God knows how many people are not going
to want to read the blog and I got oh
well where's the fucking Armor and
where's the but you're just giving the
total wrong idea what this is about is
something that is so much better and
just an entirely different creature so
this was really therapeutic when I did
this because I've seen so many people
say they liked the movie and then when
they watch my review they're like boy
that's not how I remember it at all I
remember being better or whatever it's
kind of like Avatar the blue pussy movie
you know it's like they think they
remember being better because they're
blown away by maybe the visuals of the
experience of the 3d or something
but I only watch it together and they
think about it's like this is not good
here's the thing for some man was with
your avatar eight
when this aforetime I brought that up in
a while um but second avatar was
legitimately visually interesting I
Allison wonder why was not it's good you
could go on deviantART and in five
seconds find a thousand pictures more
visually interesting than anything that
Tim Burton's Alice in Wonderland game is
it really that's the thing like it just
was not interesting to look at it was
drab you know for Wonderland I didn't
think it was all that colorful it just
was like hey let's take Allison what I
might and suck all the life oh yeah so
yeah that's a visually interest no and
even with the original animation you
just don't get it you're not dark enough
yeah that's it uh even with the original
Allison one with the animated one most
of that is in shadow but by god when
they use color when they use the designs
when they use the angles is like they
knew how to use the blank space they
knew how to make it still so interesting
the colors popped out so much more and
here it's like well we have this dark
background but you know here's kind of a
gray blue or a grey in red or gray
whatever and that's not interesting to
look at uh sorry I really want this
movie um and it like I said I don't know
if I he hates it actually more than I do
I don't know as I said the first time I
was indifferent to it was like that was
very mad the second time I'm like I
don't like this movie you on the other
hand or just iron - it was applying to
get this mad but it's like I said when I
think of the original story and I just
think how much I'm encouraging more of
this that's a sign of a bad movie though
when you think about it you can feel
your blood boil Oh kind of I mean it's
one of those things where it's like
because I what we're talking about which
ones to do I'm like well we have
whatever hot samosas Jones because I
still can't fresh my mind and I'm just
looking for other reviews I'm like Alice
in Wonderland that was a big hit you
know like in the reviews let's do that
and they like just exploded yeah it's
just one of those things where it's like
talk about an incredible opportunity
because I just still have not gotten
that perfect adaptation that anime
Disney was as close as we've gotten but
like we said they're missing a lot would
you go a miniseries what the NBC one I
like a lot of them close to the book but
had no life to it you know it's a pretty
good description yeah no but that's the
thing with a lot of them a lot and fall
into that Christmas Carol travel while
the book does have brilliant writing uh
you still need to adapt it it can't do
work it's hard to capture both the
spirit of the book and all of the actual
things that happen yeah it's it's
topping I can maybe one or the other
like it's just like well we had all the
things that helped in the book yeah but
it's lifeless or wow this is really full
of life but the man you cut half the
book out um
I generally am of the sort that I prefer
you rather have life in your movie then
follow the book by the letter yeah oh
honey - and the nice thing about the
Burton film is it tonight
it was lifeless and not - there uh so
yes but but that's why I mean it's like
I do read this book and it just you know
both of them they just have like this
franca that a word they do it there's
one or two it just a Sur reality and
even though you could argue you know
Alice
yeah she's curious but there's not much
to her it makes you realize with the
original anime Disney one just how much
the writing and especially that actress
and the animation brought to that role
oh they're always bonkers that's the way
it should there's like she is not a
boring she is actually into you want to
follow her and and you're with her and
she's a little bit potential bonhomie
there is nothing there is nothing about
the Burton film that was really bunk
is the vote no it took out we in Sanyo
look out the magnets the Queen the Queen
of Hearts is the closest thing to being
bonkers and I want to kill her for it
like yeah she's the closest thing to
just being like completely insane
everybody else is like we got a plan
we're gonna take this it's like I like
really she's the closest thing to
legitimate Wonderland is the Queen of
Hearts I just never seen a such a big
hit movie take such a big hit book I
mean a classic that we're still reading
years later and just say let's take out
everything that was fun
intelligent and surreal about me just
take it all out and we'll go it's like
no no it's just I I think it's the fact
that it was a hit as well and people
just didn't understand why lights weird
someone else in went away it's weird and
it's like there is just no respect for
the possibility of imagination and just
the just the focus you still need you
know it doesn't always mean limitations
it just means determining what is
discipline what is the point of that
Alyssa Wonderland it's a I mean to me
it's a fun little xscape into so reality
just like you know but wink logic behind
what is the point to have an experience
for me they have a very surreal
experience if it's just like that an
actual point I'll probably not point
exactly
it's pointless yeah what is the point of
the bargain Tony Bridge the man from
sure never knows oh and in Mad Hatter
you know time with the bloody Red Queen
she's crazy
we're not crazy I just thought that mad
fucking Hatter
I'm so proud what surprise Ellis didn't
just let them kill each other like let
them are you still with us in this at
all
I mean well clearly she's not the actors
who give a shit but it's like there's no
reason be invested even as a dream goes
because she always think maybe the party
was supposed to represent an adult world
trying to bring an interest
our sit okay with us logic basically
it's not about stuff like that it just
the man queen is trying to for the Queen
of Hearts is trying to enforce logic on
the world that has no lot so Care Bears
in Wonderland City and then I was gonna
say I being the interesting that would
be an interesting way to approach it and
be a threat in but she had not she's
just as crazy so the crazy ones are
trying to basically using like logic and
adult logic basically let's go to war
like it just makes that maybe that was
the secret I just said it makes no sense
maybe it doesn't make any sense maybe
Burton wasn't was no brilliant than we
thought oh god it's crazy it's what we
we crazy what a missed opportunity just
what a great chance to have a really a
directors done great stuff and a story
with so many great possibilities you
know and it's like here they go match
made in heaven
mmm I mean just totally missing that's
the no you're right here they totally
never said this is the problem I have a
lot of bad Burton films is they don't
feel like Burton films you can almost
sense the autopilot hmm the kind of
nature of like y'all provide some
drawings and yeah I'll say action but
yeah like it's almost like the studio
has a control of it and they're just
like no do this do that it's very
paint-by-number I wonder if it's a
project he's really like you watch
something like fucking big fish or his
early works like you can sense the
passion there this I just didn't even
feel any passion for any character maybe
the Mad Hatter a little I felt some
passion or maybe I guess a but I've had
a pillar for me uh yeah but I thought
you might know but even like the
Cheshire Cat looks great but when you
see him talking of revolutions and stuff
like that I'm like no it just hurts it
just hurts it really I love the story so
much apparently he's a communist to this
right yeah so it it just hurts if you
like the movie I will never understand
it um but you know to go ahead like it
but I mean don't try to convince me your
urine I'm in way too deep a pit of hate
to be dried out too like this bill
please send all hate mail to double
curse very Center but but again be the
review does great was a like the third
or fourth most-watched or something like
that's always when when people just like
you guys you're good
you kiss me you review Jurassic world in
the nose in the numbers shoot up yes
like I'm expecting a soggy I'm sorry you
watch this like 500,000 child yeah I'm
sorry everybody keeps watching you show
to me um but uh know that this was one
like I said cuz it's like it was just
these two great things I really love and
you think would go hand-in-hand and just
really I mean just went the total
opposite direction of where they were
supposed to go and just took like 20
steps backwards and we rewarded it but
that's what that's on top of being so
bad we said good give us another one
what is this we Kemosabe in rewarded wow
it I mean I forgot about it the second I
left so I just excited to do a bump
review and a delete oh great this -
Craig so um yep there you go that was
quite around I did not expect it to get
that angry haha
yeah what a point on the Tim Burton
shaped doll where the movie are you here
yeah so yeah that's about it hopefully
I'll be more calm in the next one ah
pray wondering by the way uh play so
we're still catching up the Steven
universe be logs we're going to have
those coming next week there should be a
lot of so we are catching up here we've
we also got a lot of stuff we're adding
to a DVD as well so that's also catching
us up but yeah you'll have probably more
positivity there and hipper and I like
that you yeah I chose fun fact that
shows more like Elsa Wonderland of
fucking Alice in Wonderland
um till a little too much logic but way
less logic them yeah so um that's about
it will see it the next one later